The United States had big plans for the Moon,
and the Apollo Program was just the start.
As the public dreamt of a new home in the
stars, NASA developed plans to make cosmic
colonization a reality.
The Apollo missions were laying the foundation
for life on the lunar landscape.
But, just three years after the first landing,
the United States ventured to the Moon for
the final time.
In the 1960’s, NASA was developing ambitious
offshoots for the Apollo Program - primarily
establishment of a Moon base intended to extend
humanity’s time on the Moon.
The Lunar Shelter-Laboratory or SHELAB was
one of the concepts under consideration.
SHELAB consisted of a cabin with an airlock
chamber and a lunar excursion truck equipped
with a flying belt for the astronauts.
Powered by fuel cells and batteries, the shelter
would support two astronauts for 14 days.
It was believed that the lunar bases could
be the start of a large permanent colony on
the Moon.
At the time, expanding on Apollo wasn’t
so far fetched.
The country’s Cold War competition and desire
to be first rapidly expanded the potential
of space exploration.
Two years after NASA began operations, the
U.S. government allocated 500 million dollars
of the federal budget to the agency.
In just five years, the budget grew to 5.2
billion dollars which represented 5.3 percent
of all government spending.
NASA expanded facilities across the country:
the Manned Spacecraft Center in Houston, the
Launch Operations Center at Cape Canaveral
in Florida and the Mississippi Test Facility.
With the massive expansion came hundreds of
thousands of jobs.
NASA’s labor force peaked in the mid 60’s
with a reported 400,000 staffers and contractors.
The majority of NASA’s resources went to
the Apollo Program.
Between 1959 and 1973, the agency spent just
over 23 billion dollars on human spaceflight
of which nearly 20 billion dollars was for
Apollo.
That amount of money today would equate to
over 130 billion dollars spent on one program
alone.
But by the 1970’s, public attention was
no longer above the clouds.
With the lunar landing achieved, attention
shifted to the seemingly endless Vietnam War.
And that’s where government funds went as
well, putting a huge strain on the U.S. economy.
NASA’s glory years were starting to lose
their grandiose glow.
Budget cuts forced the agency to rethink the
feasibility of its exploration plans.
And since the Apollo Program was expensive
and risky, the agency’s priorities started
to move towards other projects.
Ultimately, NASA decided to cut the Apollo
Program and its deep space dreams, short.
In 1970, the flights planned for Apollo 15,
19 and 20 were cancelled, and the remaining
missions were renumbered.
The cancelled missions freed up resources
for NASA’s Skylab and Space Shuttle - programs
that were slated to launch over the next two
decades.
Some of the astronauts who spent years training
for Apollo, were reassigned to these programs
while others retired without ever making it
to space.
The Apollo 17 astronauts would be the last
men to land on the Moon.
Veteran Gene Cernan would embark on his second
lunar trek.
During Apollo 10, he hovered above the surface
but this time he’d touch down.
The other final moonwalker was Jack Schmitt.
He was the first scientist to be selected
for an Apollo crew.
And rookie Ronald Evans would man the Command
Module while his crewmates journeyed to the
Moon.
Apollo 17 launched on December 7th, 1972.
NASA selected the Taurus-Littrow region as
the mission’s landing location.
The nearby Shorty Crater was believed to hold
evidence of past volcanic vents and geologist
turned astronaut Jack Schmitt would help provide
vital insight of the area.
En route to the Moon, the astronauts got a
view of home that had never been seen before.
One of the astronauts grabbed a camera and
snapped a picture.
It’s known as the Blue Marble Shot and it
is the first photograph to capture the entire
Earth.
The picture became the center of a decades
long debate between the Apollo 17 crew members,
each claiming they were the photographer.
After the snapshot, the crew made it to lunar
orbit and eventually landed on the Moon without
major issue.
The astronauts deployed scientific instruments
and collected lunar samples.
At the end of their first trip in the Lunar
Rover, they hit a problem.
But just like Apollo 13, this snag would be
solved with duct tape.
With the LVR running again, the team ventured
to the rim of the Shorty Crater where they
observed orange soil, which was later found
to be tiny spheres of colored glass likely
from a volcanic vent.
After about three days and a record 22 hours
spent outside the lunar module, the astronauts
prepared to head back to Earth for the last
time.
And with that, NASA’s missions to the Moon
came to a close.
The ambitious goals of the early Apollo Program
had fallen like dominos synchronized with
NASA’s depleting budget.
The space agency moved on to other projects
that would remain in Low Earth Orbit.
Apollo 17 marked the world’s last manned
trip to another celestial body.
But while the Apollo Program came to an end,
it’s contributions to science did not.
And now, decades later, NASA is tracing a
new path to the Moon.
The Apollo Program revolutionized all aspects
of spaceflight.
To learn more about the development of the
first lunar vehicle, check out this video.
You can find the rest of the Apollo series
on the Seeker playlist page.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!
The Apollo Program revolutionized all aspects
of spaceflight.
To learn more about the development of the
first lunar vehicle, watch the episode we
posted in the comments.
And make sure to follow Seeker for more science
in your feed.
Thanks for watching!